on prime crime
i don't know what's wrong
the questions surrounding a
three-year-old girl what happened here
from the intense
you you will interrogations
to the incredible admissions on the
witness stand did you lie to the police
told them what they wanted to hear
[Music]
hi there everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime crime this is where we
do a deeper dive into the most high
profile and memorable true crime cases
in 2018 a father drops off his daughter
with a babysitter but it doesn't end
with him picking her up
[Music]
[Music]
on march 8 2018 babysitter lindsey
parton alerts ohio police that the
toddler she watches suddenly collapsed
[Music]
that three-year-old girl was hannah
weschy
[Music]
after hannah is rushed to the hospital
parton who is a mother herself is
brought in to speak with law enforcement
so we walked in she was in front of me
and she went to take off her jacket and
just fell forward
and
like i said i said hand yeah what are
you doing i thought maybe she tripped
because i had
was putting my robe down
i'm like i'm in shock
detectives need to figure out what
exactly happened here including whether
this was an accident
you know that she's mischievous hannah
and that when she's at home
with her dad
that he's very busy and he doesn't get
to pay attention yeah
but i'll say other people you jump off
the couch again because
she jumps off my couch a lot
what happens in these cases is you'll
have some type of an explanation usually
an innocent explanation because we've
all been around kids we all know that
kids fall down they get bumps and they
get bruises and that's something that
we've all shared in our common
experience
yet it's when detectives reveal hannah's
condition to parton that the interview
changes
whatever happened to her happens
that she has a severe
severe friendly oh my god so what we
need is the truth from you
but yeah
i swear god i'm telling you the exact
truth
i believe you're not being honest with
us and you need to complain about it
because you're going to be a part of
this ten days after collapsing
hannah weshe would be pronounced dead
these child abuse cases come right down
to the observable injuries babies
toddlers they don't just die all of a
sudden
they were able to observe things that
are cathode pneumonic for child abuse in
other words the only explanation
for the existence of these observable
injuries retinal hemorrhages brain
swelling is inflicted trauma
parton goes back to the beginning of the
day and she explains something
interesting she says hannah's father
jason brought his daughter over and she
was wearing a hood
was it carrier
obviously right now
you know the kiss goodbye whatever he's
not back to kitchen
detectives question whether jason may be
at fault
is jason capable of this
does he have a temper have you ever seen
it
have you ever seen him hit the kids no i
haven't
but i
have not known him long enough to know
that and
i've never even been in his house have
you ever seen bruises on her
really it could only be one of two
people it was either harton
or it was him because they literally had
their hands on this child and passed her
off within moments of each other
i just know she's been beat that's the
cause of her death today
i would never hurt her jason's telling
us that she gets hurt a lot at your
house that she always comes on the
bruises
that's completely injured she comes to
my house
coming up pardon sits down for a second
interview and it doesn't go the same as
the first
you go through every single one of these
injuries and you have no problems
telling us about these
why lie about this one
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate lawn crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
this child was beat
this is abuse
they've just pulled a plug on this child
this child is dead
[Music]
oh my god
in 2018 detectives are questioning
babysitter lindsey parton about the
death of her neighbor three-year-old
hannah weschy parton claimed she was
watching hannah when she suddenly
collapsed in front of her
police though don't quite believe that
story considering the toddler's
significant head trauma indicating
physical abuse
someone will be very matter of fact with
you
if you're sitting here
telling the truth that's great
but if you're sitting here and you're
covering
and you know things
listen to the words i'm going to tell
you
you will be
there's absolutely no positive way that
this child was sitting down playing
having conversations that it absolutely
could not have happened
it is highly unlikely that she would
have been able to have been injured the
day before because treating doctors
specifically stated that the blows to
her head would have resulted within
seconds or minutes
she wouldn't have been able to be
functioning
i would love you i've never heard a kid
in my life i wouldn't even hurt my kids
i don't spank i don't think he was
is called in for a second interview with
law enforcement it's here where she
explains away hannah's various injuries
yep
exactly where she fell and on her chin
she didn't even her hand didn't even hit
like she just so all these small little
bruises
and the ones on the chin yes i know
about those right there that's all
that's from there yes
when she looked up at me and said buddy
can i have donut and couch and went to
take her jacket off and she fell
she fell on that side
this is bruised on both sides
[Music]
children can certainly injure themselves
in falls we've all seen it every toddler
falls down they have a few bumps and
bruises along the way
and yet they're not the same types of
injuries
what's the difference is the severity
and the number and the location
so when people fall
you're gonna have bruising on the sharp
points you fall straight forward you're
not going to have
bruising over here and that's what
that's what we're getting that's why we
wanted to come down and fill in some of
these holes yeah
because
i mean honestly
a lot of these aren't enough to fall on
the gravel
it's at this point when parton tells the
detectives that she left something out
of her story about what happened prior
to hannah suddenly collapsing
so i slipped on her blanket
i opened the door
and we both went down
i was
holding her on the left side when i
slipped in her side
i actually hit my head on the door
coming down but she smacked her face
her head really hurt
and i fell and she fell so so why would
you remind me
i don't know the very beginning she
basically said i don't know what
happened she just came in and said couch
donut and then she collapsed well no the
shortfall that you're describing does
not comport with the injuries
now
we have the biggest problem for miss
pardon which is that she's already by
her own admission caught being
untruthful about what happened with the
child
but parton is about to make an admission
that will dramatically affect this whole
case
[Music]
not only does she confess to having
abused hannah but listen to what she
says she did after hannah's father
dropped his daughter off for the last
time
she didn't want me to go to work
and he's like i gotta go i gotta go so
he rushed out and i was like hannah you
can't do that daddy's gotta go to work
you sure yeah
i shook her and i remember came here
from squeezing her and we did fall
how hard did you shave her shoulder she
was in trouble
yeah and you were angry
lindsay parton is eventually charged
with child endangerment manslaughter and
murder for the death of hannah weschy
yet it's what happens at parton's trial
that further complicates this story
you didn't know
that admitting to shaking hannah
would get you in trouble
no i didn't think it would
when we return
[Music]
[Music]
in 2019 ohio babysitter lindsay parton
stands accused of killing three-year-old
hannah weshe a child who was in her care
when she passed out and later died at a
hospital
after parton admits to investigators
that she had physically disciplined
hannah namely by hitting and shaking the
toddler she's charged with murder
involuntary manslaughter and child
endangerment
parton's trial began in april of that
year
we don't know exactly what happened here
we only need
to prove that hannah was abused
and or that
the defendant violated her duty to that
child
parton's defense argued that she didn't
cause hannah's death in fact they say
the toddler collapsed within a minute of
having been dropped off at parton's
house and it's possible her injuries
could have resulted from something or
someone else
so she can't say it was 20 minutes she
can't say it was an hour she can't save
days
because that's reasonable doubt that
says this child was injured somewhere
else not in the 30 seconds not in the
minute that lindsay harton had her
the problem with autopsies and most
forensic evidence is we don't know how
the trauma was inflicted
so that's why that's always a battle of
the experts
do you have an opinion to a reasonable
degree of medical certainty as to
whether or not hannah could have been
walking or talking or behaving in a
normal fashion after receiving the
injuries
that resulted in her death she could not
this is a tremendous brain injury this
is really serious
if the state's pathologist had testified
as to a significant or severe force you
would disagree with that
yeah
the autopsy shows beyond any doubt
that this child died as a result of
homicide this child died as a result of
inflicted trauma the defense experts
testified that these injuries although
they do exist didn't necessarily
manifest themselves in one certain time
frame that you could pinpoint of who was
responsible so that window
when the entries might have been
inflicted is open
in this case i do not believe it was
immediate for the for the simple reason
that the impact does not impress me
about being a type the type of impact
where i would have coup and contra and
fractures and
being some plural and all that and
didn't happen
if parton didn't inflict these injuries
then who did
the defense pointed the finger at
hannah's father jason weshee
you immediately shoved that thing into
reverse and got the heck out of the
driveway yeah when i'm leaving for it
yes ma'am i started is that when hannah
fell in the back seat hit her head
hannah never fell in the back seat
because if she fell in the back seat
climbing over the front seat and hit her
head and it killed her then you'd be
responsible wasn't that true i assumed i
would yes ma'am
i think the defense had to go with the
most easily blameable person in a lot of
times when there is violence it is
within spouses or within appearance
and we also know that he had observed
some strange behaviors from her
in addition to some of the things that
he said that were not true in terms of
going out to get milk there were several
details that wound up not being accurate
today
is the first time
you've told
detective turner in this room
that
you didn't go get milk the night before
but instead you went to fairfield no
ma'am
when did you previously tell him that
when i found out monday morning we were
in court
i indicated that your whereabouts for
the night of the seventh of march were
very important and suspicious doesn't
have anything to do with that no ma'am
you lied to the police about milk and
walmart correct
i was confused just ma'am
i found jason to be
relatively credible
he did have some inconsistencies with
minor facts they couldn't be explained
by the trauma he was going through
missing his child overall he made a good
witness
up next the jury would get to hear from
another witness maybe the most important
one of all
lindsay parton herself
ms barton did you think that you could
slap her across the face
i have known other moms to do that
that's not so i didn't think that it was
an issue as a
type of discipline
i think all court shows are the same
we're talking about your father guilty
or not guilty guilty think again judge
caprio rules with common sense i was
having contractions i was rushing to the
hospital inspector quinn what does
justice demand jail
and compassion i'm going to take the
circumstances into consideration the
best court experience i've had clearly
judge he's been in a court before
get caught in providence
[Music]
bless him like this
knowing that we know that
what happened here
i just slapped her on that head
like that
yeah like that
in 2019 lindsey parton is facing charges
of murder involuntary manslaughter and
child endangerment out in ohio
the prosecution claimed that parton
killed three-year-old hannah weshee by
physically abusing her during a
babysitting session parton had even
previously admitted to striking and
shaking the toddler the defense though
argued that hannah died due to injuries
she sustained before being dropped off
at parton's home that day even throwing
suspicions on hannah's father jason in
the end it was parton herself who tried
to convince the jury of her innocence
when she took the stand
lindsay did you cause harm to hannah
weshee on march 8th i did not
why did you tell the police that you did
because i wanted to protect everybody
miss parton took the witness stand and
she had a very tough road to hold
because she had to explain to jurors why
she herself
shouldn't be believed
she by her own admission was untruthful
during the interrogation
if she can lie to the police the
prosecution prosecution's going to say
well then she can certainly lie to the
jurors
why didn't you throw jason to the wolves
to the detectives on march 8th
because i care about him he was
my friend
wanted to protect everybody i didn't
want anybody to be in trouble
why would you want to protect someone
who did this to a child
i always think the best of people
when she told jurors that she was
protecting people
she's doing that at the expense of the
child because she's not protecting the
child if she wanted to protect the child
she would have told the truth about who
actually did this as soon as it happened
harton claimed that police coerced her
confession
we know what this is consistently yeah
look at me we'll do this for a living no
i know this is not the first
three-year-old that we're sharing
pictures about okay
it's not a fall
and you know what caused this
they didn't care what i had to say
i felt pressured i felt forced i wanted
to protect everybody i felt bullied
did you lie to the police
i told them what they wanted to hear i
did not think that the interview was
overly suggestive
we see many different types of police
interviews and a lot of them have very
obvious elements of duress this was just
not one of those examples specifically
because she actually testified to
details that were not given to her by
police
when it was time for the prosecution to
cross-examine parton
they didn't hold back
you didn't google how to make a bruise
look better how to make a bruise feel
better you googled how to get rid of a
bruise is that right yes
you indicated that it was your belief
you could physically discipline hannah
yes
you could squeeze her
middle yes
was it your belief that you could hit
her on the face with an open hand
yes
and was it your belief that you could
hit her on the chin with a closed fist
yes
and it was your belief that you could
shake her
yes
it's always difficult for defendant to
decide whether or not to testify at
trial
particularly when there are statements
that are being used against them so the
decision to testify was risky and in
this instance it did not pay off she
universally came off very poorly on the
stand appeared to be condescending
i think here it was a mistake to testify
as to count four of the indictment
involuntary manslaughter
we the julian panel jury do find the
defendant lindsey pardon guilty
accompanied by all 12 signatures
as to count five of the indictment
endangering children
through the julian panel jury do find
the defendant lindsay pardon guilty
as to count six of the indictment
murder
we the julian panel jury do find the
defendant lindsay pardon guilty
all 12 signatures the jurors gave miss
parton an opportunity to be heard and
they just didn't believe her the
testimony that she gave ultimately was
totally inconsistent with the physical
observable injuries on the child and the
jury's verdict reflects that
i do sentence the defendant lindsey
parton to a
lifetime imprisonment
with parole eligibility after 15 years
it's hard to predict whether mrs parton
is going to make parole
parole boards don't often like to parole
people who have committed very violent
offenses like this but if she behaves
tries to better herself and takes
responsibility she may be able to
convince the parole board that she is
rehabilitated
it's something that's in my mind every
single day
time doesn't make anything easier
um
it makes it rougher
try to go day by day
i was relieved that that part was over
and she was convicted um
i'm glad she went to prison obviously
we hope that she does not make parole in
2037.
i didn't see her testimony
in court i was not allowed in the
courtroom at that time
it's bewildering i don't understand how
anybody could
think that that's okay
to do to a child
it is so hard to think about hannah
weschy and what she went through and
it's even more scary that lindsay parton
almost got away with it
having said that it seems that miss
parton is going to remain locked up
until her parole hearing because at the
time of this taping the 12th district
court of appeals upheld her convictions
and the ohio supreme court declined to
hear her case
that's all we have for you here on prime
crime leave us your comments on
instagram and twitter with the hashtag
prime crime as always thank you for
joining us and until next time be safe
[Music]
you